sie nennen das politisches Versagen ja
und sagen wie kann das eigentlich sein
ist ja die Frage die viele Leute haben
wir haben zwar 15 2 16 wir hatten
Bundestagswahl 22 und wann immer man
versucht hat auch mit jemandem der
politischen Vertreter hier in der
Sendung darüber zu reden Migration
schien kein Thema zu sein absolut und
jetzt stehen wir vor einer
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz Morgen und
es ist eine Show Down Situation ja die
Länder wollen mehr Geld haben der
Kanzler sagt wir geben schon genug man
fragt sich so ein bisschen ich meine
dieses Thema ist doch nicht vom Himmel
gefallen ja wir reden seit ein
mindestens einem Jahr jetzt auch über
die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge wir haben
jetzt mittlerweile über eine Millionen
ukrainische Flüchtlinge wir haben
steigende Asylanträge sind glaube ich
über 100.000 allein in diesem Jahr also
man hätte schon auf die Idee kommen
können auch als Bundeskanzler da
vielleicht mal etwas früher dieses Thema
zu Chefsache zu machen und Gipfel im
Kanzleramt einzubuchen ne jetzt ist
nicht nur Olaf Scholz daran Schuld ja in
dieser Situation das wäre auch ein
bisschen billig glaube ich das zu
behaupten
Kinder sind natürlich auch gierig ja in
dieser Diskussion sie wollen immer
irgendwie Geld haben und das ist in
vielen Krisensituationen der letzten
Jahre ja auch passiert dass der Bund am
Ende immer gezahlt hat in der
corona-pandemie war das so auch in der
Bildungskrise ist das so und sie
verlassen sich so ein bisschen darauf
dass der Kanzler am Ende die Schatulle
öffnet ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
das passieren wird er ist da auch in der
Zwickmühle ich glaube aber nicht sicher
ob das überhaupt was bringen wird also
wir haben ja diese fatale Neigung
Problem lächelt schon und nickt Neigung
Probleme einfach mit Geld zu lösen und
wenn das Problem nicht weggeht wollen
wir aber noch mehr Geld raus in der
Hoffnung dass es dann endlich
verschwindet und stellen dann plötzlich
fest ach nee das funktioniert so nicht
der vor allen Dingen ist das Geld nicht
das Problem
das Problem ist ja ein ganz anderes und
man könnte man einen Gipfel zum Problem
machen das wäre sinnvoller und zwar was
ist eigentlich unsere Politik zu diesem
Thema
weil ein steht wirklich fest und ein und
das wirklich dramatisch dass selbst das
nicht wirklich verinnerlicht wurde es
darf nicht mehr die Situation geben die
richtig mit Kontrollverlust beschrieben
wurde das war das ist eine Erschütterung
der Autorität des Staates und seiner
Legitimation wenn das wieder erfolgt und
das war so dramatisch dass man
eigentlich hätte glauben können dass man
an dem Thema dranbleibt und man bleibt
nicht am Thema dran ich glaube dass eine
der Lehren sein müsste dass man hier
einen nationalen Konsens herbeiführen
muss und nicht streiten sollte es muss
ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Thema
bei den bis auf eine Partei alle
Verlierer sind wenn es nicht gelöst wird
und dann ist es natürlich ein
europäisches Thema die
kommissionspräsidentin hat vor ungefähr
zwei Jahren Vorschläge gemacht und jetzt
wird gestritten über Geldverteilung als
als Folge des Problems aber nicht über
Problemlösungen
ich teile diese Einschätzung das können
wir uns wirklich nicht leisten und sie
ist wirklich jetzt eine Minute vor zwölf
dass man das Problem das ist im übrigen
auch innenpolitisch hoch gefährlich ja
auch für den Kanzler und die und die
Kanzlerpartei ich meine wir sehen seit
2015 wie sensibel dieses Thema ist ja
wer davon profitiert wenn das nicht
gelöst wird wenn es im Parteien Getränk
untergeht das ist die AFD das sind die
Extremisten und die Populisten und
dieses Thema muss gelöst werden ist
völlig klar liegt im Interesse sozusagen
im Grunde genommen aller
gleich darüber reden was da
möglicherweise morgen rauskommt oder
rauskommen sollte Frau sie kennen nicht
nur die Verhältnisse in der Türkei sehr
gut auch dort Migration eine riesiges
Thema auch im Wahlkampf sie leben in der
Schweiz ne richtig auch dort riesiges
Thema und immer dieser hat das mehrfach
selbst erlebt dieser verwunderte Blick
was machen die deutschen da eigentlich
in der Schweiz ja dem ist so und ähm in
der Schweiz versteht man eigentlich
nicht man versteht eigentlich nicht dass
die Zuwanderung hier aus Schweizer
Perspektive so wenig kontrolliert wird
oder bzw das zuwanderungssystem das ist
nicht so reguliert ist wie in der
Schweiz also bei dem Thema Abschiebung
das ist in der Schweiz wesentlich
schneller organisiert das ist nicht
solche Sachen wie jahrelange Duldung
kettendungen etc das gibt es in der
südverfahren ganz genau das gibt es in
der Schweiz eigentlich viel weniger bis
gar nicht und das ist ja mitunter auch
ein Grund warum die Schweiz auch als
Asylland also kein attraktives Ziel ja
Leute einfach durch ne
sie finden Leute auch einfach durch und
sie picken sich auch die Rosinen aus
also wenn es um das Thema Zuwanderung
geht und man hat da wenig Verständnis
für oder sorgt für Irritation dass es in
Deutschland aus Schweizer Perspektive ja
nicht so läuft aber es ist noch mal ganz
anders in der Türkei weil sie das jetzt
gerade angesprochen haben weil
der wird auch noch mal auf Deutschland
was zu kommen je nachdem wie die Wahlen
ausgehen werden am Wochenende
so oder so wird auf Deutschland was zu
kommen
schwierig aber muss das Wahlergebnis
abwarten also die Türkei hat ja rund 4
Millionen Flüchtlinge aufgenommen das
heißt die Türkei ist das Land das
weltweit die meisten Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen hat das muss man auch
erstmal würdigen die Türkei hat das
teilweise auch sehr gut gemacht solange
Zeit über Jahre hinweg gab es einen gab
es eine Gastfreundschaft das ist gekippt
seit einigen Jahren wegen der
Wirtschaftskrise und das Thema
fluchtmigration ist eines der
wahlkampf-theben schlechthin und das
wird interessanterweise vor allem von
den Sozialdemokraten besetzt von der dhp
die
Herausforderer von Erdogan genau
der von der Mitte Partei Linkspartei je
nachdem wie man sieht der macht vor
allem Wahlkampf und nicht nur vor allem
der macht viel Wahlkampf genau
unterbrechen wie kommt er gleich ganz
explizit dazu nur noch kurz der ja
Historiker wenn ich das richtige Kopf
habe und der eine sehr internationalen
Blick hat
der Rest der Welt auf uns speziell auch
bei diesem Thema
naja der Rest der Welt schaut auf uns
als ein sehr verwundbaren Kontinent wir
haben halt relativ durchlässige Grenzen
wir sind nicht wirklich in der Lage nach
vielen vielen Jahren das Problem der
Meere die ja eigentlich eine sehr klare
Grenze sind
die halt eben zu einer Grenze zu machen
wo man eben einerseits die die man gerne
rein lassen möchte den die man helfen
möchte
und den die man vielleicht nicht will
dazu differenzieren dass das haben wir
nicht geschafft wir haben die
verteilungsmechanismen nicht geschafft
und das sehen natürlich
autoritäre Herrschaft von denen Europa
hier umgeben ist und diese autoritären
Herrscher machen eben dann immer wieder
abwechselnd oder teilweise gleichzeitig
auch damit Politik und erpressen die
Europäische Union das hat Erdogan
gemacht im Jahre 2019 das hat Lukas
schenko in Belarus gemacht
wir werden es jetzt vielleicht in
Tunesien sehen mit dem neuen autoritären
Herrscher der ja dieses Land das zehn
Jahre lang sich ganz hoffnungsvoll
demokratisch entwickelten und plötzlich
zurück in eine Autokratie gerutscht ist
und halt eben auch ein Hub ist für
Menschen die nach Europa kommen müssen
so und diese Art von Erpressbarkeit
erkennen viele und fahren dann teilweise
mit uns wirklich Schlitten also ich
glaube wir müssen in Europa uns wirklich
verständigen auf Regeln und diesen Druck
von Autokraten die Menschen in einen in
einer Art Waffe gegen Europa Formen dass
wir damit umgehen können und deshalb ist
es so wahnsinnig wichtig dass wir uns
einigen und dass ich erstmal man sich in
Deutschland sie gerade sagten die fahren
mit und Schlitten die fahren vor allen
Dingen mit diesen armen Leuten unfassbar
ein ein zynisches ekelhaftes Spiel das
auf dem Rücken von vielen armen Leuten
gespielt wird
morgen rauskommen das was da jetzt Rede
steht der ändert ja sehr an das was
Horst Seehofer schon mal vorgetragen hat
und damit wären wir bei der Union
es gibt Morgen für Morgen zwei Themen
und ich denke das eine Thema steht
deutlicher noch im Vordergrund als das
andere Thema und dass das im Vordergrund
steht ist das Geld das ist glaube ich
erstmal das dringlichste gesprochen wird
dass die Länder sie ernsthaft das ist
unser ganzer Ansatz nein das ist sie
fragen mich ja was ich erwarte und
darüber dass darüber am meisten
gestritten wird das ist meine Erwartung
für diesen Gipfel morgen der
Bundeskanzler der erklärt es gibt nicht
es gibt nämlich schon genug und es ist
eure Aufgabe Länder und ihr habt dafür
schon viel Geld bekommen im übrigen hat
der uns über Jahre so erpresst dass ihr
inzwischen mehr steueranteile habt ihr
Länder als der Bund ihr habt ein
Überschuss wir haben Schulden machen
müssen und darum gibt es nichts und die
Länder sagen auch als Stellvertreter für
die Kommunen die Probleme kommen bei uns
an und ihr könnt uns damit nicht alleine
lassen so das ist der von dem Showdown
von dem sie gestern gesprochen haben das
ist total
konfrontativ und das ist für das Thema
total falsch und das zweite worum es
geht ist dass man da wird auch darüber
gesprochen werden dass man sich
verständigt auf europäische gemeinsame
Maßnahmen und da stehen Grenzkontrollen
und Verfahren durchgeführt an den EU
Außengrenzen ganz mit vorne dran
darauf kann man sich in Deutschland
wahrscheinlich sogar eher verständigen
das ist in der Koalition auch noch
umstritten aber das Tabu das da jetzt ja
zum Beispiel also wenn man das wurde von
der cdu/csu vorgeschlagen in der letzten
großen Position
abgelehnt ja auch von internation
vorgeschlagen von der SPD abgelehnt als
Koalitionspartner von den Grünen also
attackiert als als Inhumanität und ähm
aber es ist aber die
bundesinnenministerin von der SPD jetzt
hat sich auf diesen Kurs der auch von
der EU-Kommission vorgegeben wird im
Wesentlichen begeben der Punkt ist nur
das ist sie haben völlig recht das kann
man vielleicht sogar als Tabubruch
beschreiben wenn es sich dahin
entwickelt der Punkt ist nur man muss
dann auch mit den EU Grenzländern
sprechen und man also dass wir in
Deutschland sagen das soll an der EU
Außengrenze Geschehen wir sind kein Land
mit einer EU Außengrenze also dass wir
sagen das soll mal die Italiener regeln
das wird nicht die Lösung das Problem
sein dass die Deutschen beschließen die
Italiener sollen das Problem lösen denn
dort gibt es schon Probleme genug also
haben und die Franzosen und die
Italiener und es gibt jetzt schon ja
beachtliche Konflikte zwischen
Frankreich und Italien bei diesem Thema
das heißt mein plädoyer für einen
deutschen nationalen Konsens und zwar
von der von vom Konzept bis zum Geld ist
eigentlich nur die Vorstufe dazu dass
man eine europäische Antwort darauf
findet die hat viel mit Solidarität zu
tun wir haben ein solidaritätsproblem in
Europa aber es muss am Ende europäisch
gelöst werden denn unsere Aufgabe ist
doch deutlich schwieriger als die der
Schweiz die ist von Europa der EU
umgeben ist er hat ein Schutzraum um
sich das ist eine ziemlich andere
Situation als die riesigen langen
Außengrenzen mal Maritim mal äh vom Land
her sind die Wege und wir sind eben auch
das ist ein Unterschied
und das wird sich das wird ausgenutzt
wir sind moralisch verbunden super sie
haben das eben gesagt nicht mit uns das
würde ich sagen dann habe ich auch
gezockt nicht mit uns wird Schlitten
gefahren sondern es werden Menschen als
erpressungs- als Geiseln benutzt von von
Lukaschenko und von anderen und wir wir
reagieren wir sind human empfindsam und
darum ist das für uns etwas was wir
nicht sozusagen
zurückdrängen sondern wir haben eine
humanitäre Verpflichtung die wir auch
abwägen müssen mit dem Gebot dass unsere
Grenzen kontrolliert werden und kein
Kontrollverlust Eintritt das macht es
Wahnsinn können Sie uns mal vielleicht
einmal mitnehmen weil er medica doch
genau den Punkt wenn er sagt 25 15 2 16
ist diese Situation entstanden es sind
im Nachgang wichtige und gute Bücher
geschrieben worden und anderem von von
Kollegen Alexander und anderen der diese
entscheidenden 200 Tage mal ganz milus
rekonstriert hat und so weiter
man hat sich zerstritten man hat über
eine Obergrenze von 200.000 gesprochen
so wie sie in diesem Jahr läuft werden
wir wahrscheinlich bei 300.000 Menschen
zusätzlich zu denen die aus der Ukraine
gekommen sind zusätzlich landen das
heißt die Situation ist eine völlig
andere als
2015/2016 das Problem ist größer ohne
dass ich damit sagen will dass Menschen
ein Problem sind aber wir ordnen es
nicht auf der anderen Seite haben wir im
vergangenen Jahr das die Zahl die wir im
Hinterkopf rumschwirrt 13.000 Menschen
abgeschoben und 300.000
ausreisepflichtigen so
das heißt ein ganzes System funktioniert
nicht
wir brauchen zweieinhalb Jahre überhaupt
das Asylverfahren zu durchlaufen
ungefähr dann erfahren Menschen ob sie
abgeschoben werden oder nicht ich will
mir nicht mehr sicher ob diese 13.000
die wir abgeschoben haben ob das die
sind von denen wir wirklich wollen dass
sie abgeschoben werden auch nicht sicher
und dann gibt es Intensivtäter die
fahren weiter Bahn und bringen Menschen
wie kommt es zu so einer katastrophalen
Situation warum verschweigt die Politik
dieses Thema so lange
bis es nicht mehr geht
ohne Vorwürfe ihre Partei ganz
entscheidend
warum tut man sich so schwer das
Offensichtliche zu benennen und dann
darüber zu diskutieren was zu tun sein
also der erste Punkt ist der den Medien
eben genannt hat dass
man wenn man die Erfahrung gemacht hat
in dem was wir flüchtlingskrise nennen
das auch im Bewusstsein hatten auch
Maßnahmen beschlossen hat dass dann die
Aufmerksamkeit mit dem Rückgang des
Problems abnimmt und damit das ist und
das eigentlich der entscheidende Fehler
in aber alle machen Politik aber auch
die öffentliche Begleitung sagen dann
dann verschwindet das Thema wieder auch
im Handlungsdruck weil die
Öffentlichkeit für dieses Thema
verschwindet und es kommt ein anderes
Thema sagen wir mal Donald Trump wird
gewählt 2016 das ist dann ist das hier
ein ganz anderes Thema dann haben wir
den Krieg und haben wir wieder andere
Themen und das ist der eigentliche
Fehler das selbst bei derartig
absolut sozusagen ja fast existenziellen
Themen
wir als Gesellschaft aber auch die
Politik an diesen Themen nicht dran
bleibt und vielleicht auch sogar die
Ruhephase nutzt um zu Lösungen zu kommen
das ist der entscheidende Fehler aus
meiner Sicht dass wir dass wir nicht auf
dass wir nicht beim Thema dran bleiben
sondern jetzt wenn die Zahlen sich
wieder so entwickeln wie seit Beginn des
Jahres fängt man wieder an reaktiv auf
mit sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen
ohne dass man die Zwischenzeit genutzt
hat im Konzept weiterzukommen das ist
die Art das ist eigentlich das Muster
wie wir uns mit aber warum warum aber
warum also den ja warum also ein
bisschen komisch weil ich bin eine ich
bin eigentlich ein Prediger gegen die
Veränderung dieses mutet man Menschen
die Wahrheit nicht zu ist Menschen die
Wahrheit nicht zu zumuten
ist die also ich glaube das also mal
ganz allgemein kann es sein es war ja
bei der ersten flüchtlingskrise so es
war auch bei der Pandemie so die über
die ja von Experten angekündigt war dass
wir mit Russland in Energieabhängigkeit
gekommen sind war es also wir haben es
mit absehbaren Entwicklungen zu tun
immer wieder aber und die werden man
entscheidet wir beschäftigen uns nicht
damit wir tun sonst würden wir es nicht
sehen und die Politik fängt an zu
agieren besser zu gesagt zu reagieren zu
reparieren wenn der Schadensfall da ist
fast auch zu überkompensieren dann
natürlich manchmal dann kommt das
möglicherweise auch zu Übertreibung das
ist die das ist insofern wirklich gut
dass man das mal auch so darstellen kann
das ist ein Muster
von politischem Verhalten aber warum
verrückt warum warum warum warum also
noch mal ich bin jetzt also ich an
deutscher Spitzenpolitiker der ins Amt
kommen möchte so unfassbar schwer damit
zunächst mal eine klare Diagnose zu
stellen um dann zu sagen wir lösen das
Problem so oder so selbst wenn ich dabei
Fehler mache selbst wenn das ein oder
andere nicht funktioniert aber ich will
es zumindest mal versuchen ich habe das
also
warum wird es warum
bringen ich und andere damit nicht durch
wahrscheinlich also jetzt bin ich dabei
etwas zurechtfertigen was ich immer
kritisiere ja also versuchen einen
politischen Mechanismus oder eine
Wechselwirkung glaube ich Mechanismus
dürfte sein dass die politikbilanziert
ein Thema das keine Öffentlichkeit hat
für das Thema für die Beschäftigung mit
diesem Thema damit geht dafür gibt es
kein Honorar dafür habe davon habe ich
nicht noch mal wenn das Thema in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht stattfindet ja dann
brauche ich das nicht zur Bank damit
keine Wahl ja das war alles immer dann
ich mache
doch mal Ressourcen verwenden und das
Thema ist nicht in der Öffentlichkeit
und dann mache ich Vorschläge die
kontrovers sind und ich werde eigentlich
nur Kritik dafür ernten aber nicht
nichts Positives dafür Ernst das heißt
wenn Sie wenn Sie das ist unter vier
Augen unter Achtung unter 16 Augen in im
kleinen Kreis auch mit ihren Kolleginnen
und Kollegen darüber reden sagt wir
haben dann echtes Thema
hört man dann den Satz lass mal da
gewinnt man im Moment kein Blumentopf
das will keiner hören nein das sind die
die reflektieren das auch kritisch sie
können Sie uns auf diese können Sie auf
Klimawandel übertragen sie können es
übrigens auch auf Artenschutz
Biodiversität hat überhaupt ist ein
riesen Thema eine Bedrohung unseres
Planeten aber es hat überhaupt keine
Öffentlichkeit und wenn Sie darum jetzt
Vorschläge machen die ja auch den
Menschen etwas zumuten auch eine
Kontroverse auch bei diesem Thema dann
ist die herrschende Kalkulation wir
haben davon nichts meine gegen These ist
ja das stimmt das ist ein anstrengender
Weg und es wird auch Kritik werden du
wirst auch Nachteile dafür leiden mein
zentrales Argument ist wir Höhlen auf
die Dauer wenn wir immer wieder der
Bevölkerung sagen ihr seid nicht auf der
Höhe der Zeit bei den Problemen und die
hätte das Wissen können ihr habt jetzt
wo das Problem da ist kein Konzept und
keine Lösungsansätze deine Höhlen wir
die Akzeptanz von Demokratie und von
diesem starken das ist mein dringendes
aber wir müssen wirklich auch mehr
werden dass diejenigen die sich mit den
Problemen beschäftigen wenn Sie die
Öffentlichkeit nicht da ist auch dafür
etwas drei Profis die hier sitzt und
alle drei wollen habe ich den Eindruck
ich teile das total ich glaube ich will
auch gar nicht rechtfertigen ich glaube
am Ende sind Politiker eben auch nur
Menschen also es ist unheimlich
anstrengend in einer Phase wo es keine
Aufmerksamkeit für ein Thema gibt dieses
Thema zu pushen also man stelle sich mal
vor die bundesinnenministerin nennt sie
Faser hätte sagen wir 2018 oder so als
die Flüchtlingssituation einigermaßen
entspannt war gesagt ich will jetzt die
EU Außengrenzen schützen wir bauen Zaun
um Europa was das für eine Debatte nach
sich gezogen hätte sie hätte keine
Chance gehabt jetzt sagt sie das und
alle sagen ja ja müssen wir irgendwie
machen also die diskursverschiebung die
nimmt man dann natürlich so mit ja ähm
stimmt ich bin doch gar nicht sicher ob
die These stimmt dass man mit diesem
Thema nicht hätte realisieren können ich
glaube dass das Land sehr dankbar
gewesen wäre wenn wir mal klar darüber
gesprochen gut aber es gibt natürlich
immer noch klassische Unterschiede ich
würde jetzt sagen weil wenn man vom
Thema Abschiebungen herkommen klar kann
man über Abstimmungen hart reden aber es
gibt da natürlich auch menschlichkeits
Aspekte humanitätsaspekte und so die in
so einer Kanzlerpartei SPD natürlich
immer eine Rolle spielen das sieht man
jetzt gerade auch bei Frau Feser in
ihrer Doppelrolle als Spitzenkandidatin
einerseits und als bundesinnenministerin
sie kann sich natürlich in der
Migrationspolitik als Wahlkämpferin
nicht angreifbar machen von rechts
deswegen intoniert sie relativ hart und
relativ entschlossen das wiederum führt
in ihre eigenen Partei sorgt ihr für
Probleme heute zum Beispiel ja Jessica
Rosenthal die josef-vorsitzender hat
gesagt wo ist denn hier eigentlich die
humanitäre Migrationspolitik bei uns
geblieben ja also das ist eine eine
Ambivalenz eine schwierige Doppelrolle
kennen Sie wahrscheinlich noch aus ihrer
Zeit damals in Nordrhein-Westfalen ja so
eine Doppelrolle immer immer
problematisch
ich wollte noch mal Hinweisen auf diesen
auf die enorme Bedeutung die Hilfe die
rechtzeitig geleistete Hilfe auch
spielen kann
die flüchtlingskrise 2015 ist ja unter
unter anderem auch dadurch ausgelöst
worden dass in den Flüchtlingslagern die
um die um Syrien herunterladen gar nicht
ausreichend geholfen hat und das damals
tatsächlich auch von verschiedenen
internationalen Organisationen die hat
nicht genügend Geld und dann hat sich
etwas aufgebaut was man einfach
verschlafen hatte und das passiert
natürlich immer wieder und jetzt muss
man aber auch heute einmal sagen es gibt
ein positives Beispiel wie man halt eben
Menschen rechtzeitig geholfen hat denn
machen wir uns keine Illusion es könnten
aus der Ukraine zu uns auch wesentlich
mehr Menschen kommen die dringend um um
Hilfe suchen die in Not sind und die
Europäische Union hilft eben derzeit
auch in der Ukraine sich stabilisiert
den ukrainischen Staat eben auch mit
Hilfe und ich halte dieses im Grunde
genommen wiederum finde sehr
weitsichtige Politik
um zu verhindern dass Menschen aus China
not Haus und hoch verlassen müssen also
man insoweit ist läuft auch nicht gerade
alles schieben aber man muss sicherlich
in der in der Frage wie wie aus anderen
Ländern jetzt Menschen kommen und wir
nicht die möglichen
differenzierungsmittel haben darüber
muss man natürlich reden